♪ ♪
>> Laura: REMEMBER WHEN
NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO
AND CLAIMED HE NEEDED 30,000
VENTS WITHIN TWO WEEKS.
WELL, IF HE DIDN’T GET THEM, HE
SAID PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DIE.
IT WAS REALLY SCARY.
WE AT "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" WERE
SKEPTICAL, THE NUMBER SEEMED
ABSURDLY HIGH BASED ON THE
REVISED DATA, WHICH WE STARTED
TALKING ABOUT ON TUESDAY NIGHT
WITH DR. FAUCI.
WELL, IT TURNS OUT WE WERE
RIGHT.
>> YES, THEY ARE IN A STOCKPILE,
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE IN, BECAUSE WE
DON’T NEED THEM YET.
WE NEED THEM FOR THE APEX.
>> Laura: WELL, JOINING ME NOW
IS RUDY GIULIANI, FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR.
RUDY, GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
HE SAID THEY ARE IN A STOCKPILE,
WHERE THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE.
THE PRESIDENT SEEMED A LITTLE
PERTURBED TODAY, THAT THEY SEND,
I DON’T KNOW, 4,000 -- I DON’T
KNOW HOW MANY EXACTLY ARRIVED,
BUT THEY WERE A LOT, AND THEY
ARE NOT DEPLOYED ANYWHERE, THEY
ARE JUST SITTING THERE.
WHAT ABOUT CUOMO, AND IS HE
TAKING CARE OF HIS STATE THE WAY
HE SHOULD BE?
MAY BE OVER PROJECTING, BUT WHY
IS THAT A BAD THING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I THINK, BY AND
LARGE, HE’S DONE A REALLY
GOOD JOB, AND THE PRESIDENT HAS
DONE A SUPERB JOB.
THERE IS A TENDENCY TO
OVERSTATE.
I WENT THROUGH THIS A NUMBER OF
TIMES, WITH WEST NILE VIRUS,
ANTHRAX, 9/11.
I TRY NOT TO BECAUSE I DON’T
WANT TO LOSE CREDIBILITY.
AND ONE CASE, I WAS DEALING WITH
THE CLINTON, SO DEALING WITH THE
OPPOSITE PROBLEM.
THE OTHER CASE, I WAS DEALING
WITH PRESIDENT BUSH.
UNDERSTOOD, THE PRESIDENT HAS
DEMANDS FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
AND ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
I DON’T WANT MY DEMAND TO LOOK
RIDICULOUS.
NOW, THIS LOOKS LIKE A CASE
WHERE THEY DIDN’T KNOW -- THE
RIGHT HAND DIDN’T KNOW WHAT THE
LEFT HAND WAS DOING, WHICH CAN
HAPPEN IN A SITUATION LIKE THIS.
YOU BACK OFF, MAYBE MAKE AN
APOLOGY FOR IT.
>> Laura: YEAH, I THINK THAT
IS RIGHT, AND I THINK THE
PRESIDENT HAS SAID MANY TIMES --
WHICH I THINK, AGAIN, IS WHY HIS
NUMBERS -- NOT THAT THAT IS WHAT
IS IMPORTANT, BUT PEOPLE LIKE
THE FACT THAT HE SAYS I WILL
WORK WITH ANYBODY.
TO GET THIS COUNTRY GOING AGAIN
TO PROTECT PEOPLE I DON’T CARE
WHERE YOU COME FROM, WHAT PARTY
YOU COME FROM, WHAT COMPANY YOU
COME FROM, I WILL WORK WITH
ANYBODY.
THAT’S THE KIND OF THING WE NEED
TO HEAR IN A CRISIS -- IN MY
VIEW.
YOU DID THAT AFTER 9/11.
YOU DID THE SAME THING.
>> A LITTLE ADVICE TO GOVERNORS
AND THE MAYORS, HAVING BEEN IN
THAT POSITION FOR THREE
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT
SITUATIONS.
I WOULD SAY ONE EQUAL TO THIS.
TAKE THE BLAME WHEN YOU HAVE TO.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU PLAY WITH
YOUR BOSS, SOMETIMES IT’S BETTER
IF YOU DON’T WIN THE GOLF GAME.
HE’S THE BOSS.
HE’S GOT ALL THE RESOURCES.
I DON’T SAY THAT HE IS GOING TO
BE AFFECTED AT GIVING OUT
RESOURCES ONE WAY OR ANOTHER,
BUT IT’S JUST HUMAN NATURE THAT
IF YOU ACT LIKE A RESPONSIBLE
GUY, AND HE’S GOT REAL
CONFIDENCE THAT YOU ARE DOING
WHAT YOU ARE DOING, HE’S GOING
TO GIVE YOU EVERYTHING YOU WANT.
I THINK YOU COULD ASK
PRESIDENT BUSH TO THIS DAY, I
DON’T THINK THERE’S A SINGLE
THING I ASKED HIM FOR HE DIDN’T
GIVE ME RIGHT AWAY.
I DON’T THINK THERE IS A SINGLE
THING I ASKED THEM FOR THAT I
DIDN’T REALLY, REALLY NEED TO.
SO THAT’S THE KIND OF CONFIDENCE
THAT HAS TO DEVELOP.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS HAPPENING
BETWEEN TRUMP AND CUOMO, MAYBE
EVEN DO SOME.
LET’S SAY WE CAN GET BACK ON IT.
BY AND LARGE, COMPARED TO SOME
OF THE OTHERS, LIKE MY
COMPLETELY ABSENT MAYOR, CUOMO
IS A HERO.
>> Laura: de BLASIO IS
STILL -- WE DON’T HAVE TO DO
BELABOR THE POINT, BUT
DE BLASIO HAS BEEN SMASHING THE
PRESIDENT.
>> HE LET PEOPLE OUT OF PRISON!
>> Laura: YEAH, WELL, THAT --
THIS CRAZY JUDGE JUST YESTERDAY,
RUDY, LET OUT THIS GUY WHO
STABBED HIS GIRLFRIEND MULTIPLE
TIMES IN THE CHEST FROM RIKERS,
ORDERED HIM AND 15 OTHERS
RELEASED, BECAUSE THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR HEALTH AT
RIKERS ISLAND.
I’M THINKING, BUSY GUY MURDERING
HIS GIRLFRIEND IN JUNE OF 2018.
THIS IS THE CASE I’M PUTTING UP
ON THE SCREEN FOR YOU.
AND NOW, THIS GUY IS GOING TO GO
FREE.
A MURDERER.
>> HAVE A REALLY GONE WACKO?
THE REASON THEY ARE ARGUING THEY
SHOULD GET OUT OF RIKERS ISLAND
IS RIKERS ISLAND IS RAMPANT,
RAMPANT, WITH CORONAVIRUS.
SO WE ARE PUTTING OUT ON THE
STREET PEOPLE COMING FROM A
PLACE THAT IS RAMPANT WITH
CORONAVIRUS.
INTO A CITY --
>> Laura: ON THE STREETS.
>> AND I’M BEING TOLD TO STAY
HOME.
I’M BEING TOLD TO STAY IN MY
APARTMENT.
DON’T LEAVE.
OR AS LITTLE AS POSSIBLE.
[LAUGHS]
I MEAN, THIS IS CRAZY.
I WANTED TO BRING YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE REPORT, 669 CASES TREATED
WITH HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, AND THE
AZITHROMYCIN, AND HE ADDED THINK
TO IT.
SO FAR, 669 CASES, FIVE
HOSPITALIZATIONS, TWO INTO
PATIENT’S, NO DEATHS.
WHERE TALKING PEOPLE OVER 70
YEARS OLD.
>> Laura: WE ARE SEEING GREAT
RESULTS.
BUT RUDY, YOU’VE SEEN THIS IN
YOUR CAREER IN POLITICS AND YOUR
TIME IN GOVERNMENT, FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE GOVERNMENT.
YOU GET THE SENSE THAT THE
MEDIA, THEY DON’T ALMOST -- SOME
OF THEM DON’T WANT THINGS TO GO
BACK TO NORMAL IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY LIKE THIS CRISIS POINT AND
THEY DON’T WANT THINGS TO GO
BACK TO NORMAL.
AS THE NEWS COMES IN THAT MIGHT
BE SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN WE
THOUGHT, THEY ARE ANGRIER AND
GRUMPIER THAN THEY SHOULD BE.
IT’S ON.
>> I COULD HARDLY FIND -- I
HEARD IT, AND I WANTED TO SEE IT
AGAIN, I WANTED TO SAY IT IN AN
INTERVIEW THIS MORNING, THE
EXACT WORDS.
THINGS ARE ALMOST BURIED.
THAT’S BIG NEWS.
ATAT ONE TIME, WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE FATALITIES TEN TIMES THE
FLU.
NOW WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
FATALITIES CLOSER TO --
>> Laura: ABOUT THE SAME.
>> YES.
GREAT NEWS!
>> Laura: REALLY BIG NEWS, THE
MORTALITY RATE --